here now with more on both these races
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
Senator it's a pretty dark business you
chose to be and I'll say that
um but it is what it is and you know I
know the gloves are off against Herschel
Walker he's denied the allegation about
the abortion
um there's another controversy with with
warnock's church and and kicking people
out of out of uh some housing that they
have
um and herschel's offered to pay back
rent if need be for some of those people
but you see Warnock you see his record
and you see the attacks only on Herschel
why is that
what caused the road to the majority
runs through Georgia Democrats know that
the media knows it I learned something I
didn't know what you said until tonight
I didn't know this about Warnock I just
heard it tonight well I bet nobody in
Georgia knows it because if you're
waiting on the media to tell you about
what's going on in Georgia other than
destroying Herschel Walker's life you're
going to wait a hell of a long time
remember Kavanaugh remember how they
played the game right at the end they
come up with some letter uh take the guy
Blindside another allegation another
allegation trying to drive him out what
he stood in there and I tell you what
Herschel is going to stand in there too
so this needs to be an ad what you said
needs to be turned in an ad is two
million dollars a week to run one ad in
Georgia team herschel.com Warnick has
raised 90 billion dollars herschel's
raised 30 million dollars every liberal
in the country is all in to make sure
Warnock wins in Georgia we need to be
all in for commercial so let's raise
some money tonight team herschel.com to
take what you said and tell Georgia
about Warnock because if we don't turn
it into an ad you're never going to know
it well I didn't know Senator that uh in
a domestic dispute that somebody can
make an allegation that the spouse tried
to run you over with a car and that
person didn't get arrested uh I would
think that if you're covering up an
investigation into child abuse and you
obstructed Justice in that case and in
fact it did happen and you ran the camp
how come the people of Georgia don't
know that how is it possible he got a
Superior Court ruling and got dragged
into court for not paying child support
for all the stuff that's been said about
Herschel Walker some of it he says is
absolutely not true uh where's Warnock
ever being asked a single question about
any of it
well he's never going to be asked I hope
we have a debate we're going to have one
debate Friday night I hope this is
brought up but here's herschel's problem
he's being outspent three to one he
needs to run ads talking about Warnock
voting against border security and
increasing the IRS by 87 000 votes he
needs to run ads telling the people in
Georgia that Warnock has shut down
domestic oil and gas production in the
United States making us more dependent
on foreign oil and gas and he also needs
to tell the story about the double
standard here this October surprise
against Herschel you think that's an
accident they waited this long to drop
it right before the election so here's
what you can do to help Herschel Walker
and to help your own family if you live
in Georgia vote for Herschel tell your
friends to vote Herschel if you don't
have a friend go make one if you don't
live in Georgia you can tell people you
know in Georgia vote rehearsal but all
of us can send some money tonight to
teamhercial.com so he can run two ads
now not one warnock's money is not
coming from inside of Georgia I hope the
people of Georgia know that none of it
yeah all right Senator Graham is coming
from the same damn people that tried to
destroy me and we're not going to let it
happen teammercial.com let's fight fire
with fire
Senator Graham thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else